hello and thank you Alexander Solan
niten once said that the strength or
weakness of a society depends more on
the level of its spiritual life than on
its level of
industrialization if a nation's
spiritual energies have been exhausted
he said it will not be saved from
Collapse by the most perfect government
structure or by any Industrial
Development a tree with a rotten core
cannot
stand when he was allowed to leave the
USSR so n went to the US where he was
given a hero's welcome but he quickly
realized that American society was far
from perfect he started lecturing
Americans about the problems he saw
Americans don't like
that like soulan nits and I come from
the Soviet Union but I have no intention
of repeating his
mistake that's why I've come to
Britain where you love being told what's
wrong with you by
foreigners but I do have to be honest 6
months ago when Jordan and Philippa
asked me to come here and speak at ARK
about the importance of audacity
adventure and a positive vision for our
civilization I was honored and
delighted but as I stand here today
after watching crowds openly celebrate
mass murder on the streets of our cities
after watching the police spend more
time debating Islamic theology on tter
than enforcing the law I'm starting to
lose faith I don't know how long our
civilization Will
Survive for years now many of us have
been warning that The Barbarians are at
the gates we were wrong they're
inside now look I'm not going to be all
doom and gloom there are positives as
well I mean say what you want about
Hamas supporters at least they know what
a woman
is
but joking aside I have to be honest
I've been in a dark place these last few
weeks so I did what I always do when I
don't know what to do I talk to my wife
it's not the only time I talk to her but
you know get the point and she said look
you just you need you need to clear your
mind take a few days off let's go on
holiday and I know it's a weird thing to
say I don't like going on holiday cuz I
love working and I hate spending
money Protestant work ethic in a Jewish
man's
body my wife is exactly the other way
around
unfortunately but she was right she's
always right that's her best and most
annoying quality um so we went to
Barcelona beautiful city and as we were
walking down the main tourist Street
lambla many of you will know when you
get to the bottom you hit the
Christopher Columbus Monument it looks
like a giant column with a pillar of
Columbus on top pointing towards the new
world and this reminded me of my son
Nikolai he's 16 months and this is what
he does he sits on my hip and points in
the direction he wants to
go treats me like a horse basically and
if I don't act quickly enough or if I
don't comply he does what all toddlers
do he throws a tantrum and starts
screaming how dare you you have stolen
my dreams with your empty
words
and when he does We read him a story and
put him to bed we don't give him a
standing ovation in front of the
UN anyway trigger warning I am going to
talk positively about Christopher
Columbus I know he committed some pretty
sizable
microaggressions
but he also changed the world do you
know why he changed the
world yeah he tried to reach India and
by accident discovered America but why
go west to India Europeans had been
trading with India and China for
centuries via the Silk Road why risk
your life to go out on a limb there were
many reasons of course but the main one
was the decision to try and reach Asia
by going west was not made out of choice
Europe was desper
only a few decades prior in
1453 the Ottomans sacked Constantinople
and they cut Europe off from the Silk
Road the West Was facing a huge
Challenge and a new threat no smaller
than the one we face today and like us
what they needed was another way but
when Columbus took his idea to go west
to India to the kings and queens of
medieval Europe they laughed at him they
didn't laugh at him because he was some
misunderstood genius he wasn't Galileo
they laughed at him because he was wrong
if you go out in the street and ask a
random person why Columbus discovered
America they'll tell you he worked out
that the Earth was round not true by the
time Columbus set off on his voyage in
1492 people had known the Earth was
round for two
Millennia there's probably more flat
earthers now than there were in the 15th
century God bless the
internet
the reason Columbus discovered America
is not that he'd worked out that the
Earth was round the reason is that he
massively underestimated the size of the
planet they were right to laugh at him
he was wrong but he took that wrongness
he persuaded 90 other men to get into
three boats smaller than the size of
this stage and sail into the unknown and
he persuaded Queen Isabella of Castile
and King Ferdinand of Aragon to fund his
voyage the mor moral of the story is it
doesn't matter how wrong you are as long
as you've got rich
friends that's not the moral of the
story the moral of the story is the
history of our civilization was not made
by people who always got everything
right it was made by people who' made
mistakes too it was made by people who
dared to believe that they could solve
the problems they faced the story of the
West is a story of
audacity the big debates of the last
decade the culture War the polarization
are about one thing and one thing only
the future There Are People Like Us in
this room who believe that our future is
to be prosperous powerful and
influential we are the
majority but there are also some people
whose brains have been broken by an
excess of
Education who believe that our history
is evil that we do not deserve to be
great we do not deserve to be powerful
that we must be punished for the sins of
our ancestors to them our past is
abominable abominable our present must
be spent apologizing and our future is
managed decline my message to those
people is simple how dare
you you will not steal my son's dreams
with your empty
[Applause]
words
but Jordan is right we need a positive
message too so here it is from the dawn
of time human beings have had to work to
make the world a better place we
captured the mystery of fire we invented
the wheel today we build buildings that
would shock and awe almost every human
being that has ever lived we split the
atom we spliced The genome and we
connected the world through
microcomputers that fit in our pockets
that allow us to do amazing amazing
things this morning I destroyed someone
on Twitter with facts and logic from the
toilet It's
Magic remember your
grandparents remember them if I could go
back in time and transport the
grandparents of your grandparents into
this room just four generations ago they
would think they'd been abducted by
aliens that's the progress we've made we
haven't made that progress by whining
and acting like victims we've made that
progress by unleashing the creativity
and talent of people like us here in
this room but I do think we've forgotten
what Adventure is being adventurous is
not ordering extra spicy chicken at
Nando wrong reference for this
room let me try again being adventurous
is not ordering extra spicy chicken from
your personal
chef
when Columbus and his men got on those
boats and took a journey into the
unknown they sailed to certain death you
know why it's not because they were
braver than you and I it's because they
knew something we forgotten all Death is
certain and so I say to our friends in
the world of business you've made your
fortunes by maximizing your Returns on
your Investments we are in the fight of
Our Lives
there is no greater return on your
investment than to protect and preserve
our
civilization and so I invite you to
follow in the footsteps of Elon Musk and
Paul Marshall and bandel and many of you
here who are using your fortunes for the
betterment of
humanity I say to our friends in the
media truth matters we are in the fire
of our lives there is more to life than
clicks and downloads let's move beyond
the culture War where all we do is B
away the Litany of slanderous
allegations about our history let's set
the agenda let's remind our fellow
citizens why we are where we are let's
remind them that we are the most o
tolerant open and welcoming Societies in
the history of the world we're not
embarrassed about our past we're proud
of
it and to my colleagues in New Media
especially I say this the Legacy Media
is dying for reason they cannot be saved
they cannot be reformed let's stop
complaining about them and start
building the media empires of the future
ourselves we have everything we need
we've even got rich friends
now I say to our friends in education
and Academia I understand that many of
you feel like the French Resistance or
Soviet partisans stuck Behind Enemy
Lines under demanded and outgunned and
you're right we are in the fight of our
lives so keep fighting for every young
mind you can it will be worth
[Applause]
it and finally I say to our friends in
politics many of you here are
conservatives I'm not I look terrible in
tweet that's why I identify as
politically non-binary
um but I can tell you conservative
something you will never get young
people to want to conserve a society and
an economy that is not working for them
we will not overcome woke nihilism as
long as young people are locked out of
the housing market Unable to pair up
unable to have kids unable to plan for
the
[Applause]
future I know it's it's difficult and I
know that whoever solves the housing
crisis May well pay the price at The
Ballot Box this is true of many pressing
issues too or at least you think it is
but you did not get into politics to get
reelected you got into politics to make
a
[Applause]
difference we are in the fight of our
lives and if courage means anything it
means doing the right thing and being
willing to take the punishment if you
have to let me say it again all Death is
certain we do not get to choose whether
we live or die we only get to choose
whether we live before we die thank you
very
much